it has been two years now since the
January 6th attack on the U.S Capitol on
Friday lawmakers held a ceremony on
Capitol Hill and the White House present
and at the White House President Biden
marked the solemn occasion by presenting
medals to 14 Americans for their
exemplary contributions to democracy
during the 2020 election and on January
6. Congressional correspondent Nicole
Killian spoke with three of the
recipients
in an emotional White House ceremony in
history we'll remember your names
and remember your courage President
Biden bestowed the presidential citizens
medal to those who defended democracy
including D.C metropolitan police
officer Daniel Hodges former U.S Capitol
Police Sergeant aquilino Grinnell and
Capitol Police Officer Harry Dunn what
does it mean to you to receive an honor
like this I was left completely
speechless on January 6 we just did our
job that's wild
um yeah I don't know what to say it's
it's crazy I'm honored obviously I am
humble and honored to to receive it but
to tell you the truth I didn't do it
because I wanted a medal I'd rather have
my life back
two years later the images of January 6
are still hard to escape I responded
from the East side uh we heard radio
calls screaming officers just need helps
and helps and help
once I got out of the building I looked
down it was chaos on my way up I was
attacked we were all were attacked I was
hit in the head with a metal pole punch
kicks beating
you can't look at this scene and not
think of it anymore
what is life like for you now it's very
much the same and very different as
before January 6 2021 it's
it's different because that day changed
so much
for me
and for the country my whole life had
changed Sergeant Canal who was brutally
beaten during the riot left the U.S
Capitol Police last month after the
physical and mental trauma became too
much to bear I could do a lot of things
with my left arm but I still had some
type of limitation mentally I'm still
triggered sometimes depending on what
was the issue but removing myself from
the the triggers of being here at the
Capitol every day
allowed me to to heal faster the three
men have formed a brother-like bond
since the attack knowing other officers
are going through what you went through
and have the same thoughts and feelings
about what happened it's it's a big help
because otherwise you just feel alone
it's frightening to think about how
close we were they were the first
witnesses to testify before the January
6th select committee and sat in the
front row during almost every hearing do
you feel like you've gotten some sense
of justice two years later I mean I'm
grateful for the Genesis committee they
uncover a lot of evidence there have
been prosecutions of people but at the
January 6 hearing showed us that it went
much higher than just protesters getting
out of hand
so we can't let people forget I do
believe that people have gotten tired
about tired of this
um hell I'm tired of it I I don't want
to be out here every day
fighting for accountability and Justice
with my my partners here but it needs to
be done holding the line again for CBS
Saturday morning Nicole Killian the
capital
and the thing is it will never leave
them because those are scars that stay
forever and some have as he did have
left the profession entirely I've heard
stories of people working at department
stores or in you know or in coffee shops
because the triggers are just too much
for them to bear and in many other spots
this week the anniversary sort of got
overshadowed by all the drama that was
playing out even though it was the exact
same place yeah